lock him to this video playing Cindy CD
from Brazil let's see what we get the
Kings Indian and okay yeah maybe maybe
the same ish once once again trying to
mix some variations not always this h3
line okay get a modern benoni I modern
be known you with age five yeah black
normally tries to unpin this night and
then go for night h7 yeah this is one
way to do it hmm ok Queen here okay wait
vago Queen d2 he might play be five okay
but I have Bishop h6 I always like it
when i get this exchanged always feels
like i have accomplished something maybe
i'm doing this the wrong way but
normally I like to to get this Bishop
p.m. I came he can hmm I wonder yeah I
can of course play Bishop a jade here I
can take right yeah and now I can go
even to everyone of course I don't need
to go to h1 now sometimes you have
castle they need to go to h1 and now he
again I can quickly get the night to e3
yeah I always have problems to
understand these type of positions my
assessments of this position would be
that wider sir very close to a
to a PR almost decisive advantage
because whereas flexplate where what
exactly is black doing I have a big
advantage in the center okay we can try
for our for counter play with something
95 but i have a form yeah I'm can do
that but you are never going to play
before I don't think so so the question
is before I've night see for this is
what I'm talking about okay let's see
how to do that even an endgame wouldn't
be bad but not sure that I want to want
to go to that okay I can also maybe just
castle first and see what he's doing
okay I go nite c4 he will take on on c3
ya know I've got night see for coming
and night h3 to attack the h3 pawn
Knight f2 to attack the h3 pawn you
cannot go on a g5 because of night f5
check this is an important thing to
remember yes he needs to get the Queen
away there I guess but F prepare nights
you for I am just here asking me what
what what to do about the h3 born no
here okay yeah this is very nice for
what
now I kept a kindle I can just take it
what what kind of structure is this so
that's very weak threaten even queen
before now and 93 93 is the worst air
c5f is almost gone very hard to defend
okay the only thing of course is some I
have weakened my king position slightly
so always some caution advised as long
as the Queen so our own he might have
some tricks yeah here we go it's
probably not a bad decision from
practical point of view you're going to
get completely annihilated if you don't
do anything drastic but i don't i don't
really believe it okay let's tat steak
you cannot take on d5 because of bishop
f3 and if you return to have six i take
you five with the Queen exchanging
queens now f5 that is night xe5
original s no self-penned okay I
threatened 96 he cannot play any kind of
pimp inning with no Queen B 6 anyway
happening ever born on 85 okay so takes
I guess I just take with the queen or
with the Rue Cler booth not bad yeah I
guess I think with the Ruby even
attending Roxy six okay yeah just just
take here take care to damage response
ok and now this check in check black
resigned yeah this it's too much I can I
can do all kinds of nasty things Bishop
c4 and so on yeah I think this was an
opening an opening disaster to be honest
I think that this position is already
really bad for black you lack your
bishop p.m. on g7 and I get the night 23
where's your play fff-for in the long
run gaining more space any Queen trait
is basically fatal and what to do about
94 in b5 jump and TM I don't I don't
really see how it's going to get a
satisfactory game here you can certainly
defend more tenaciously but yeah yeah
but I don't I don't really know how now
this this is not helping maybe maybe
here i have i think i can just good play
i just press play for what what are you
doing here so this is all protected this
is weak yeah computers on + 2.5 already
it's um I always feel if I can exchange
the bishop and don't need to wonder too
much with the night that white is really
just better the center discount for
something I mean came and and around
here that it gets it gets desperate now
he has no way to defend the pawn I just
attack it with 93 23 and then it's gone
yeah an opening disaster okay thanks for
watching